new details in an officer-involved  shooting from last week it happened last  wednesday on las vegas boulevard near  sunset they tell us it all started at a  gas station when a car pulled next to a  patrol car as you see the video here and  a woman got out asking for help police  say while they were talking to her the  suspect who's now been identified as 34  year old manuel martinez got out and  started firing at the officers  right there you can see it they fired  back martinez was hit but then he  somehow managed to run off was later  found and taken to a hospital  during the course of our investigation  detectives learned that martinez and the  woman who approached the officers used  to be in a dating relationship  but that relationship  ended last year  he went on to tell us martinez had asked  the woman to drive him to the hospital  before the shooting but she started to  feel unsafe and she looked to police for  help martinez now facing several charges